[Music]
this is how far we are allowed to follow
doctors and nurses to one of two
intensive care units at Howard
University Hospital this Medical Center
in Washington DC has been serving the
african-american community in the city
for over 150 years most of our patients
are poor
most of our patients live in health
deserts most of uninsured or
underinsured most are unemployed and
have other disproportionate impact what
we call social determinants of health
here in Washington and elsewhere across
the country high quality primary and
pre-emptive care can often be absent and
unaffordable in poorer neighborhoods and
communities the lack of access to
healthy food sources is another factor
that accounts for the stark difference
in numbers of Kovach 19 related death in
predominantly african-american and white
communities this is dr. Wendy Ellis she
spent years researching the root causes
and impact of what she says are systemic
inequities on predominantly African
American and other minority communities
she's not surprised that black Americans
are impacted by Kovach 19 and a
disproportionately higher rate
pre-coated you had a higher higher
proportion of individuals with
hypertension with diabetes with obesity
these things that are the leading causes
of death in the country and the chronic
does the leading chronic diseases in
this country it's not surprising that
individuals that already had that higher
proportion of those immunocompromised
diseases would then be at the higher end
of the toll anacostia one of the most
economically and socially deprived areas
in the District of Columbia Martha's
table a nonprofit organization that
serves underprivileged communities is
based here providing healthy food and
offers education on healthy food choices
among other things for many residents of
Anacostia he disparately hard by the
corona
the work carried out day in day out by
volunteers is critical this is a there's
only two grocery stores in this
neighborhood and there's a lot of people
that don't have the resources to either
get there or shop there so we came here
because we knew that this is where the
food resources were needed as well as
the education giving families healthy
food choices they normally can't afford
is perhaps just a band-aid right now but
many hope that America's coronavirus
crisis could finally trigger real policy
change that aims at making
underprivileged communities healthier
more affluent and with that more
resilient to a public health crisis in
the future
and I am joined now by calypso Schalke
du director of the global health policy
think-tank the Center for global
development in London thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon I'm and
I'd like to begin by asking you because
some have called the coronavirus a great
leveler impacting poor and rich alike
what is your response to that sort of
language I'm not so sure you've just
demonstrated using the United States as
an example how the most vulnerable and
poorest amongst the US citizens are the
worst hate and when you look at
countries unfortunately African nations
South Asian nations are much more likely
to be hit the hardest
perhaps not just the direct effects of
the virus but the effects of the global
economic shutdown that the global North
is imposing to manage the outbreak so
with that in mind what would you
recommend I mean what coronavirus
measures you think should be implemented
in less affluent countries and in less
affluent areas within countries
themselves so I think first of all one
size does not fit all I do not think
that we can take the measures imposed in
the United Kingdom or indeed the US or
France Italy and try and implement them
directly in sub-saharan African nations
for all sorts of reasons the African CDC
has issued guidance on
staged rollout of measures for
suppression but I think if we were to
pick the top three or four things
African governments could do first of
all water and sanitation low-tech water
supply we know wash interventions are
very effective and will do good after
the virus is gone in terms of saving
lives secondly when we look at social
distancing it must be done in a way
which takes account of the realities of
poor nations people live in crowded
spaces ninety percent of the people
working work in the informal sector so
these people must go to work all they
will starve to death they and their
family so must consider this as the
starting point and whilst we're talking
about scaling up hospital capacity let's
concentrate again on simple things that
we know save the most lives oxygen
physiotherapy chest physiotherapy
suction that will save lives in normal
hospital settings as opposed to
high-tech ICU ventilators which may well
not be feasible in countries without
electricity for it's simple things that
are in dire need are just briefly before
we go I'd like to ask you because we we
hear a lot about you know the global
economic impact of the corona virus and
I'd like to ask you briefly about how
you see the impact on global poverty in
particular going forward I think it's
likely to be a tragic impact we're
already looking at forecasts of millions
of people falling into poverty and this
reduction in GDP in sub-saharan Africa
which could be up to six percentage
points will directly result in hundreds
of thousands of deaths for instance we
estimate about 300,000 children will not
live to see their first birthday solely
as a result of the projected economic
contraction so this is a direct health
toll of the economic downturn calypso
shakadou of the global health policy
director of global health policy excuse
me at the Center for Global Development
in London thank you thank you